eso
[Música]
en 1854 londres sufrió una epidemia de
cólera
el doctor jones no nos dimos fondos era
un médico anestesiólogo con una teoría
radicalmente distinta sobre las causas
de la epidemia mientras que los médicos
contemporáneos creían predominantemente
en la teoría asmática es decir qué
olores y gases causaban la enfermedad
jones no que conocía sobre gracias por
sus estudios de gases anestésicos
pensaba que si fuese así el cólera
debería manifestarse con problemas en el
sistema respiratorio y no estomacal
como era el caso por eso pensaba que la
causa del cólera era por ingerir al
el doctor es no empezó a catalogar cada
muerte se empezó a notar un patrón donde
ciertas áreas tenían una cantidad
radicalmente mayor de muertos después de
comprar un mapa de soho que es un
distrito de londres decidí hacer algo
revoluciona la georreferencia acaba
muerto es decir dibujar la ubicación de
cada casa afectada y ponerla en una capa
encima del mapa
esta idea de capas o leyes en inglés es
es un concepto fundamental de sexo si
estamos de información geográfica
haciendo esto es que logra haber un
patrón espacial grupos de casas
afectadas alrededor del broad street
después de investigar un poco más
descubre que varias personas se habían
quejado de un olor extraño en el agua
que tomaban por eso decía georeferenciar
las bombas de agua es decir poner las
sujeciones del macro una capa más con
esa información convence a la ciudad de
cerrar las bombas de agua sembró street
una medida que acaba reduciendo las
muertes por cólera dramáticamente la
razón del brote era que el pozo en wall
street se estaba contaminando por
filtraciones de otros pozos con restos
fecales
sin que referenciar los casos y ponerlos
en capas sobre un mapa hubiese sido
imposible tomar la decisión de cerrar la
bomba en bros street para los médicos el
doctor si no es actualmente considerado
uno de los padres de epidemiología
pero para los geógrafos es considerado
uno de los padres del análisis red
espacial
jones no nos enseña este concepto de
análisis geográfico por capas hoy en día
todos los gobiernos del primer mundo
saben que entender la geografía que nos
rodea es esencial para tener un país
moderno es por eso que han invertido
miles de millones de dólares en
recolectar y digitalizar su información
geográfica y gravar a disposicón o
sistemas de información geográfica
lamentablemente la mayoría de peruanos
nunca han escuchado sobre estos sistemas
casi cualquier cosa se puede ser
referencia a la ubicación de nuestros
colegios centros de salud centros de
votación cualquier infraestructura está
en un lugar nuestros ríos montañas lagos
que están un lugar los clientes de
nuestras empresas nuestros vehículos
nuestros teléfonos están en un lugar
existe una infinidad de diferentes tipos
de análisis que podemos hacer cuando nos
referenciamos datos
pero tener la información recolectada de
manera digital y sólo el primer paso que
hacemos con esa información y cómo
usamos esa información y es más
importante por ejemplo muchos no saben
que el perú tiene una agencia espacial
con y manejada por fuerzas aéreas del
perú tal vez se han escuchado que el
perú adquirió un satélite de observación
del perú sac un el más moderno de
sudamérica en una compra que representa
una inversión mayor a 350 mil unidades
de dólares
pero para qué sirve este satélite ojo no
es un satélite de comunicaciones ese es
otro tipo al satélite es un satélite de
observación sirve para tomar fotos desde
el espacio
bueno en unas fotos un poco especiales
no
podemos tomar fotos de alta resolución
donde cada pixel es decir cada punto de
la foto representa 70 centímetros del
mundo real eso nos permite distinguir
objetos como en vacaciones en el litoral
peruano edificios en una ciudad
vehículos en un estacionamiento ahora
como la órbita del perú sa pasa por lo
menos un par de veces encima del perú al
día podemos tomar varias fotos en alta
resolución del mismo lugar el mismo día
digamos 1 de las 5 a la mañana y otra de
las 3 de la tarde si juntas imágenes
adquiridas en distintas fechas puedes
notar que va cambiando con el paso del
tiempo si cruzamos esos datos con
permisos de tala de los informes que es
el ente regulador de recursos forestales
en el perú podemos encontrar tal al
llegar como en este ejemplo de la pampa
madre de dios
si cruzamos esos datos con permisos de
minería de saint germain que es el ente
supervisor de permisos de minería en el
perú podemos encontrar un medio ilegal
con este ejemplo y madre de ellos
fotos de alta resolución también sirven
para el ordenamiento territorial por
ejemplo cada distrito tiene un igual un
hacienda una finca que está encima de un
terreno no a este terreno le llamamos un
predio al realizar un catastro que es un
inventario de todos los predios en un
distrito obtenemos información
importante acerca de la situación
jurídica de la tierra sabemos quién es
la dueña y por eso también sabemos quién
es responsable por el pago de los
impuestos de ese predio
es aún más importante para un municipio
del día porque el impuesto predial
representa más que el 50 por ciento de
los ingresos de un distrito aún así de
los mil 851 municipios del perú sólo la
mitad ha hecho un levantamiento
catastral y uno de cada diez lo tiene al
día es decir la mayoría de municipios en
el perú no saben que está construido en
su propio distrito a pesar que los
impuestos a esas construcciones
representan la mayor parte de sus
ingresos si se preguntan por qué siempre
hay amnistía al comienzo de un nuevo
gobierno municipal es porque la mayoría
no sabe cuántos impuestos cobrar por los
predios por no tener un catastro el día
es más fácil recibir dinero de una
autoevaluación
esto es acción a pesar que se sabe que
la actualización de un casas de un
catastro resulta en un incremento del 30
por ciento de ingresos de música
a parte de tomar fotos que podemos ver
desde el espacio que que más puedo hacer
más de satélite
pero usa tiene la habilidad de tomar
fotos de lo que podemos ver obviamente
como nos enseñaron los ejemplos pero
también de lo que no podemos saber
si pensamos en nuestras clases de física
del colegio recordaremos que los ojos
del ser humano solo pueden ver una parte
pequeña de todo el espectro de luz
durante los veranos nos ponemos lentes
de sol para proteger nuestros ojos de la
luz ultravioleta no la podemos ver pero
nos afecta nuestros controles remotos de
televisión utilizan luz infrarroja para
cambiar de canal o subir el volumen no
lo podemos ver con nuestros ojos pero
igual que la luz ultravioleta está allí
y a pesar de que los humanos no lo
podemos ver algunos animales como
serpientes insectos ratas o peces si
pueden bueno el perú sabe si puede ver y
tomar fotos del espectro infrarrojo
y esto para qué me sirve bueno resulta
que diferentes superficies reflejada la
luz de distinta manera el cemento las
plantas el agua todo alrededor de
nosotros reflejan las ondas de distinta
manera una planta sana con irrigación
correcta tiene un proceso de
fotosíntesis distinta a otra planta de
la misma especie pero con mala
irrigación otra planta que esté hacer
esa diferencia se puede notar en la
banda infrarroja
esa característica permite analizar
desde el espacio diferencias de las
mismas plantaciones para identificar
problemas con irrigación a enfermedades
en otras palabras si invertiríamos un
poco en el software de análisis
podríamos analizar todos los terrenos
agrícolas de todo el perú y mandarle un
mensaje a cada agricultor acerca de
áreas de cultivos que tienen problemas
antes de que ellos lo sepan
también sabemos que cada tipo de planta
refleja las diferentes ondas de luz de
manera distinta y esto permite crear una
firma espectral una manera de
identificar el tipo de planta
existe una rama completa de la ciencia
llamada remote sensing que estudia estas
características varias universidades
peruanas han creado una base de datos de
firmas espectrales de distintos cultivos
saben pero por ejemplo la universidad
esan barcos tienen más de 150 firmas
espectrales registrados cultivos de café
uvas pesqueras arándanos etcétera
esta imagen enseña la detección de
arándanos en valles santa en áncash
utilizamos esa firma espectral para
pintar los arándanos de color morado en
este caso verde para otros cultivos
beige para áreas sin cultivos
imagínate hacer esto a nivel nacional un
monitoreo automático de todas las zonas
de cultivo del país que te permite
predecir la producción agrícola de todos
los cultivos del perú ese año podemos
también estimar la producción de
productos derivados por ejemplo
monitorear cultivos the work disqueras
te permite estimar la producción de
pisco a nivel nacional
podemos mejorar la producción agrícola
de cultivos identificando áreas con
enfermedades o problemas de irrigación
podemos incrementar nuestra producción
agrícola en 31% como es típico en zonas
que implementan agricultura de
percepción
actualmente estas cosas se hacen con
papel y lapicera visitando la zona
agrícola también
bueno en fin el perú sab también tiene
otra habilidad que actualmente no se
está explotando la habilidad de tomar
fotos en estéreo esto permite crear
imágenes en tres dimensiones y estimar
elevaciones alturas los modelos de
elevación sirven para muchas cosas como
por ejemplo estimar el flujo de fluidos
en un relieve
este ejemplo es este mapa de elevación
del volcán obinna se mosqueó a
identifica los pueblos que serían
potencialmente destruídos en caso de una
explosión volcánica cuando el volcán en
erupción en la lava comienza a fluir por
sus surcos podemos predecir qué escuela
va a ser destruida qué calles del pueblo
van a ser afectadas o tal vez si el
único hospital o aeropuerto de la zona
va a dejar de funcionar imagínate tener
este análisis de todos los volcanes del
pene
este tipo de análisis no sólo aplica
para buscados sino también para
cualquier movimiento de cuerpos líquidos
con inundaciones causadas por lluvias
huaicos tsunamis set
toda esta información se analiza en un
sistema de información geográfica
a pesar de haber hecho grandes
inversiones en sensores cual perú sab
para medir este tipo de información el
perú no ha hecho una inversión en un
sistema nacional de información
geográfica para analizar esta
información a nivel nacional
cuál es el apuro
el 'pelusa' está diseñado para tener un
tiempo de vida de 10 años fue lanzado el
espacio en el 2016 tiene ya casi cuatro
años después de eso deja de ser
operativo y todavía no estamos
utilizando ni el 5% de lo que pueda ser
solo en este caso estamos desperdiciando
una inversión mayor a 500 millones de
dólares que ya hemos hecho
bueno la pregunta que varias se deben
estar preguntando es por qué no hacemos
estos proyectos de análisis geográficos
y pueden beneficiar a tantos sectores de
nuestro país
lo curioso es que sé exactamente por eso
que no lo hacemos porque afectan a
varios sectores en nuestro país en
general inversiones en proyectos de
sistemas de información geográfica
tienen aceras y multisectoriales
a pesar de que todos sabemos que la
tecnología es esencial para el
desarrollo del perú no existe una
instrucción que esté diseñada para este
tipo de proyectos tecnológicos
multisectoriales proyectos de tecnología
que benefician a todos que el ministerio
creen que debería estar agarra este tipo
de proyectos si se lo hace ministerio de
defensa
el énfasis va a ser en problemas de
defensa por ejemplo lucha contra el
narcotráfico el catastro no sería
prioridad se lo hace el ministerio de
economía en economía tal vez se
preocuparían mejorar los catastros para
incrementar los ingresos sobre las
principal y dades pero tales legal no
sería prioridad
si se lo hace el ministerio de
agricultura tal y félix o preocuparía en
encontrar la tala ilegal y mejorar la
producción agrícola prevención de
desastres no sería prioridad
la realidad es que el perú no tiene una
institución que tenga un presupuesto y
una mirada global multisectorial para
canalizar este tipo de proyectos otros
países como brasil colombia argentina
chile tienen ministerios de tecnología y
ciencias exactamente para este tipo de
problemas pero no
quizá la única manera de tener una
estrategia de datos geoespaciales
multisectoriales sea creando un
ministerio de tecnología y ciencias como
lo han hecho nuestros vecinos u otra
entidad similar los invito a que piensen
con mente abierta sobre qué significaría
esto y el impacto que esta entidad
tendría en nuestro país
gracias